that ladies and gentlemen is how a
14-year old really feels on their
birthday
[Music]
that's Gwen Stefani and Gavin Rossdale
son Kingston being showered with kisses
by Gwen's beau Blake Shelton when shared
the vid to her instagram on tuesday part
of her birthday tribute to her firstborn
son who turned 14 that makes it even
more exciting in enemies the no doubt
singer also posted this photo of the
birthday boy looking all grown up
rocking bleached tips and some cool
jewelry during a beach day she wished
him a happy birthday in the caption and
added quote thank you God for making me
his mama hashtag love you Kingston James
I'm excited Kingston's dad Bush rocker
Gavin Rossdale
also took to Instagram to celebrate his
son he shared a whole collection of
photos and a touching message in the
caption praising Kingston for being kind
funny smart handsome naughty spirited
articulate and dynamic Gavin also called
his son the love of his life apple of
his eye and said you know I do it all
mostly for you and your siblings right
Gwen and Gavin are also parents to
eleven-year-old Zuma and six year old
Apollo they split in 2015 and later that
year Gwen started dating Blake Shelton
[Music]
the couple spends a lot of time with
Gwen's boys they've even hit up red
carpets together I think not cool my
cool points are going up a little bit
with the kids which I need all the help
I can well I'm as for Gwen she told ET
in 2017 being a mom is tough but the
best gig in town I'm just so blessed to
have them and have so much fun
they're definitely hard work but it's a
lot of fun
[Music]